At the bottom of the hill, make a right.
Continue straight ahead.
At thenext intersection, turn left.
My name is Karen Jacobson and I'm known asthe only woman men will take directions from.
My speaking voice ended up in over a billion GPSand smartphone devices giving directions to peoplearound the world.
You have reached your destination.
Well I'll take you right back to the beginning...
I'm originally from Mackay, which is a town in NorthQueensland near Australia's Great Barrier Reef.
I wanted to become a professional singer andmove to America.
And I did follow that dream to New York.
And not long after I moved there,there was an audition
and a client was lookingfor a native Australian female voiceover artistliving in the northeast of the United States.
And I went to that audition and I got the job.
Proceed tothe route. Proceed to the route. Proceed to the route.
At the time I was told that the Australian
voice was a high priority
because the Australianaccent was considered the most pleasant English-speaking accent to listen to
which is pretty cool.
Turn left. At the roundabout, turn right.
There was a huge script, a massive script, and the team of engineers had figured out
every combinationof syllables possible for me to record
so they could chop that up and create this voice systembased on my speaking voice.
I went into the booth and recorded these different lines.
At the nextintersection, turn left. At the roundabout, turn right. You have reached your destination.
What are some other ones? Let me think...
Oh everybody's favorite: recalculating.
I had tosay the word 'approximately' approximately 168 times in a row.
There is a red light cameraapproaching.
I like to keep people safe.
When I'm asked to use the voice, I do, becauseit's fun.
My voice is going to live on forever? Wow the power is going to go to my head.
Imean that's mind-blowing. Really. Isn't it?
You have reached your destination.